on a connu beaucoup de choix sage aurait
demandé à georges brassens pour lui vous
pensez qu'un esprit militaire je n'en
sais rien je ne m'en suis jamais
tellement souci vous savez moi je suis
je suis devenu anti militariste parce
que dès l'enfance des très jeunes déjà
le j'ai eu je détestais la discipline
j'ai eu horreur de recevoir des ordres
et j'ai eu horreur d'en donner aux 6
heures de me soumettre alors petit à
petit j'étais obligé de rencontrer
l'antimilitarisme mais bernard clavel
dit qu'il a eu à dompter en lui il me
vint guerrier est ce que nous n'avons
pas fait le même chemin tous les deux
lui justement été a eu envie de porter
ce type i blanc à jouer la petite guerre
moi je n'avais jamais joué mon père
était d'ailleurs dans le même état
d'esprit je suppose que c'est lui qui me
l'avait donné quand il parlait de la
guerre d' enfant il parlait de la guerre
de 14 il haussait les épaules qui
regardaient la salle les enfants dit
s'amuser avec à la petite guerre alors
j'ai suivi mon père je pensais qu'ils
allaient lâcher ans et ça je suis pas si
c'est l'anarchisme pour le moment je
vous dis c'était le le refus de toutes
disciplines et qui menait en moi ça a
commencé très tôt je ne la réflexion du
reste je ne dis pas que j'avais raison
tour je me suis proposé cette idée vous
avez porté l'uniforme non les premières
iphone j'étais trop jeune au moment de
la guerre et devant le drapeau ça
faisait mieux drapeau non absolument pas
non moi j'aime n'aime pas ma patrie moi
j'aime la france
aucun rapport et la musique militaire en
la musique militaire me plaît parfois
beaucoup la masse et sata sûrs de temps
en temps dans mes chansons j'ai des
rides motti qui pourrait très bien faire
deux visages chez les militaires et la
marseillaise
non la musique n'est pas mal les paroles
de jean freddy ce métal